The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So first
up, we're going
to go around, do a
couple of things.
We'll just go in pairs.
We'll try these out, so
you two can come up first.
We'll start off with one
of our basic principles
of electromagnetism, which
is that we can spin metal
in a magnetic field
and produce current.
So let's hook up our
little motor to an LED
and see if we can make
our motor into a dynamo.
OK, so it works.
It's not easy, but it works.
We're using a motor
in reverse, we're
spinning metal in
a magnetic field
and producing some current
to light up our LED.
There we go.
Now, let's plug in this
to our amplifiers and
try to re-do our
telharmonium light.
So it's the turn of the century.
It's around 1900.
You're Cahill, and you're like
I need a way to produce sound.
I need the way to
create an oscillator.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Who
would have thought
that this is the
best way to do this.
STUDENT: That's what
my dad's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: We need
definitely some way
to spin this faster
so we can get a tone.
But you can hear that if it were
spinning at some constant rate
you could get--
STUDENT: This motor
has less resistance
so it continues to get a tone.
That motor's tighter,
but so you just--
STUDENT: It's got
a better motor now.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Can it work as a
musical instrument?
STUDENT: Sure, whatever.
PROFESSOR: What
would we need to do?
If you wanted it to make a--
STUDENT: You need two
interfaces, for sure.
PROFESSOR: Two parameters.
STUDENT: Maybe if
I twiddle those--
STUDENT: I got all these
parameters right here.
STUDENT: Add volume
with the turntables.
STUDENT: Yeah.
STUDENT: Oh yeah.
Sounds great.
STUDENT: And you could light
it up at the same time.
PROFESSOR: OK, next up.
OK, good.
So next up.
STUDENT: Which one do you want?
PROFESSOR: OK, so you
guys gotta work as a team.
Do you want to try the motor
while they're connected?
Actually, just feel
the motor so you
can get a little sense of how--
STUDENT: It is really hard.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Try the quick
flick you get a little bit--
STUDENT: OK, I'm done.
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
So here is our humbucker.
Two signal coils
next to each other.
Essentially, just a big wrath
of wire with some little
poles to focus the
magnetic energy.
Now, this design, this
a nice DeMarzio pickup.
I was talking
earlier, it's in pink.
I got the pink one
because it was cheaper.
Think about the issues
involved in that.
The pink pickup is cheaper than
a black one, same performance.
Anyways, this model
has four conductors
which allows us to access
each of the coils separately.
We're going to
run them in series
and treat them
just as one pickup.
So we need our--
this is our ground ,
here and this is our
hot signal, the red.
STUDENT: Does that mean
that you're essentially
eliminating any benefits of
the reverse polarity humbucking
action?
PROFESSOR: The humbucking
action works into both series
and parallel, according to
the DeMarzio literature.
STUDENT: It seems
like if you ran them
in series that
reversing them again,
you would just knock out
the sequel altogether.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you got it in?
Now, the first thing to
try is turning our motor--
before we get to the phone.
Now, what this
device is going to do
is pick up moving metal that
perturbs the magnetic field.
So if we spin our motor
in front of the pickup,
let's see if we can get a sound.
There we go, OK?
STUDENT: It's the same sound.
PROFESSOR: It's the same
sound, that's right.
Which shouldn't be
surprising, but it is still.
OK, good.
Now, what if we put a vibrating
metal string on top of this?
Maybe we might pick
up a sound, right?
Let's try it on piano.
OK, so one of you can play
the keys here and hold down
the damper.
And the other needs to--
STUDENT: Feedback?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you're
going to get feedback.
STUDENT: Try to go
for a lower one.
PROFESSOR: It has a high
directionality action.
STUDENT: Maybe if we
do a really quiet note.
PROFESSOR: So it really
matters is the location.
There we go.
Maybe turn off the distortion.
STUDENT: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
Try it again.
Now just move it--
hold on one note.
Press that one note
repeatedly and move the pickup
to the left and
right so we can hear
how focused the
pickup is on that.
This is pretty interesting.
Now, if you actually
rest it on the keys.
Now we have to prepare the
electromagnetic feedback.
Now, we could try to do
some sort of ebo thing
where we direct the
acoustic energy out
of the pickup on the strings.
STUDENT: Out of the pickup?
PROFESSOR: Out of the
amp onto the strings.
STUDENT: Oh.
STUDENT: All right.
PROFESSOR: Now, this
isn't going to work great,
but the idea here is that
we're using the amplification
to re-resonate the
string and creating
a feedback loop in the process.
STUDENT: Want me
to start it off?
STUDENT: Ah, yes.
PROFESSOR: Hold down
the damper, too.
And actually, if you
rest it on the keys,
you're probably going--
The damper's way up.
STUDENT: Yeah.
Nice.
PROFESSOR: Now,
change the position
of the speaker a little bit.
See if you can--
STUDENT: Yeah.
STUDENT: I wish I had
an expensive piano.
PROFESSOR: OK, great.
Good.
OK, guys.
Good job.
Who do we want.
Next up.
Leave the pickup
connected and now we
need some sort of
devices that give off
electromagnetic radiation.
Does anybody have a device
that gives off some radiation?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So let's
try the phone first.
Just hold the phone
over the device.
STUDENT: OK.
PROFESSOR: Well, you can
move it around a little bit.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So we're
getting some notes here.
Try the iPhone.
It's full.
STUDENT: You getting a text?
PROFESSOR: Just hold it
slowly and now move it.
STUDENT: Whoa!
STUDENT: Wow.
Now I know why they say
it gives you cancer.
PROFESSOR: Now move
it up and down.
Can we make this some sort
of musical instrument?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: If we put
processes through some delays
and filters, we could get
some really nice sound.
There we go.
Now, that's when
it goes to sleep.
I found that last night.
STUDENT: Oh, neat!
PROFESSOR: I don't
know exactly--
STUDENT: And then chirp
is it's periodically
reading the accelerometer--
PROFESSOR: Is that what it--
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: But it's asleep.
STUDENT: And then when it
sees the new measurement,
it wakes up again and throws
the chip into power mode.
PROFESSOR: Oh really?
STUDENT: Because the chips
can still sample really,
like once every
second or something
they can take a sample
off the accelerometer.
PROFESSOR: So who knew
you had a passive--
STUDENT: That's amazing
that you can hear that.
STUDENT: That's really cool.
STUDENT: There's some sci
channel attacks just waiting
to be exploited.
STUDENT: Is that sound
in the background?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's like the ground noise.
STUDENT: No, it
sounds nice there.
PROFESSOR: Now, if you have
some vibrating uses in here.
We have some special, using
the vibrations of the phone.
Let's try these out.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: Control using this--
the purple side on the switch.
PROFESSOR: I bet since
the speakers are magnetic,
they would actually
just act as a microphone
if you just played
sound on them.
STUDENT: Whoa.
STUDENT: Wow.
That's nice.
STUDENT: It's
actually [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: Does it vibrate?
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's giving
us a good tone right there.
OK, so that works well.
Oh, nice.
STUDENT: Are you
squeezing it hard?
STUDENT: Nice.
STUDENT: Right in
the middle though.
STUDENT: I got a happy message.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Now, you mentioned about
what about a speaker.
So what is a conventional
acoustic speaker?
How does it work?
STUDENT: Coil, magnet.
PROFESSOR: Coil and a magnet
moving back and forth.
So these things have
speakers in them, right?
And if we play some music,
like a little Afrika Bambaataa.
So this is not
acoustic transduction.
This is electromagnetic.
And notice how tight
the directionality is.
STUDENT: It's actually a
pretty nice conduction there.
When she holds it just right
it's almost as good as a wire.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
is a queue.
OK, great.
Thanks, guys.
Now, Greg, did I see a
phonograph project there?
OK.
Let's see if we can
do some with that.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Does it work?
STUDENT: I don't know.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So anybody want to guess?
Red is maybe hot, obviously.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let's try connecting
red to the positive, which
is yellow for us.
And then let's try
hooking up the black,
or is that blue, to--
this might be a stereo.
Do you know if it's a stereo?
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Stereo.
So let's see if you move the
needle, do you hear anything?
STUDENT: How does
that come from that?
STUDENT: Yeah.
STUDENT: It's just noise.
STUDENT: So where is it--
STUDENT: It's right there, yeah.
STUDENT: I don't
want to break it.
STUDENT: Let's try the white.
STUDENT: The iPhone pickup.
STUDENT: There we go.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Hey.
There we go.
There's something there.
So the basic--
STUDENT: Oh no.
PROFESSOR: Now, see if you can--
STUDENT: Oh!
PROFESSOR: Lords of Canada,
you don't like them?
STUDENT: That's terrible.
That was a terrible bootleg.
STUDENT: A little
faster than that.
PROFESSOR: You want to be in the
groove, so try to line it up.
STUDENT: In the groove.
STUDENT: In the records.
STUDENT: The initial movement.
STUDENT: Was red.
PROFESSOR: There's a
little something there.
STUDENT: And don't
forget to push hard.
OK.
Well, that's not--
PROFESSOR: We'll try
this again later.
The basic principle of
a phonograph needle,
how does it work?
STUDENT: Coil and magnet.
PROFESSOR: Coil, magnet.
So the arm, that the
stylus is connected
to a metal that's moving
in a magnetic field.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
OK, great.
We'll play with that
a little bit more.
I want you guys to get started
on building some modulators.
So you guys can go
back to your seats.
So Collins, in the great
tradition of hardware hacking
has an approach for us
to build oscillators
using a digital chip
that's not intended
to be used as an
oscillator at all.
You guys will work in pairs.
You can work with your neighbor.
STUDENT: Oh, whoa.
Look at that.
STUDENT: Nice.
STUDENT: Try not
to lose anything
in the first couple of seconds.
PROFESSOR: So Collins has us use
the Hex Schmitt Trigger, which
is a very simple device which
allows us to basically flip
and flop between
a 0 and 1 output.
Namely, which will
be a voltage allowing
us to alter between
two voltages.
Now, what we're going to with
this chip is we're simply
going to use pins one and two.
We're going to use one
of these little triggers,
and we're going to feed
it back into itself
and cause it to oscillate.
So now you all
have your chips in,
except for those of you
that don't have chips,
so let me give you some chips.
STUDENT: I can't guarantee
it won't break up, but I--
PROFESSOR: And you need
some-- good on ground,
and good on power.
OK, cool.
STUDENT: We are set up somewhat.
We are ready.
And then we need to do what?
We need to feed it back.
STUDENT: We apparently want
to feedback one and two--
STUDENT: So you want
sound out somehow.
STUDENT: Which component
do you think is--
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the first thing we need to
do is provide power to our chip.
That's already done on the
boards that I gave you.
You want to take vector,
these here, and orient
the ground on the bottom.
Orient the ground on the bottom.
OK, so you want it
to look like this.
Orient the ground
and the bottom,
and connect power
to the power bus,
and the ground to
the ground bus.
And you guys need--
STUDENT: You have to
register to one and two.
Cap from what, one to ground?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: I think.
And then he's got sound.
STUDENT: This single round
and this one is in two?
STUDENT: Yeah.
Exactly.
And that's the--
STUDENT: There we go.
We made sound.
STUDENT: Check for heat.
PROFESSOR: OK, wait
for the [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
OK, ground, good, good.
And then you got the
resister feeding back
into the second pin.
OK.
Good.
You guys need some components.
We should have our
basic oscillator set up.
Excellent.
And let's hear what we get.
Let's plug it in and
see if we get a sound.
There we go.
The beauty of synthesis.
STUDENT: That sounds good
with everybody's in there.
Is everyone using the
same value and components?
STUDENT: Oh, nice.
You're screwing the capacitance.
STUDENT: How'd you do that?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] resistance.
PROFESSOR: Good.
OK.
STUDENT: No, it's capacitance.
It goes between your two fingers
with the parallel capacitor.
STUDENT: No, I am
bypassing the resistor.
STUDENT: Oh.
Nice.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good.
And--
STUDENT: This sounds awesome
with everybody's going at once.
STUDENT: I don't think.
I'm just guessing.
STUDENT: I don't think at all.
Sorry.
STUDENT: Then cover it up.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Yes.
Oh, hey, got it.
STUDENT: In nine holes?
STUDENT: Yeah.
STUDENT: Oh yeah,
I don't know how--
I don't know if we
can get reliable--
STUDENT: Yeah.
The bands are really--
STUDENT: I don't know
what those bands mean,
or whether they
would even like--
STUDENT: Oh, you're going
to try the white hat?
STUDENT: Not bad at all.
STUDENT: That is awesome.
STUDENT: We did a good thing.
STUDENT: All right.
STUDENT: I like that tone.
STUDENT: I love that tone.
It's really nice.
PROFESSOR: OK.
STUDENT: Just swap it out,
hot swap it for the speaker.
Are we going to try this mode?
STUDENT: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
You got a sound.
Make sure you got a sound.
STUDENT: Let's maybe slow it
down and try the resistor gain.
But instead of so
high, use the--
STUDENT: What if we
tried the other one?
STUDENT: Wait.
You guys pause for a sec?
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Pause for a sec.
We're going to make
sure these guys who
are doing ultimate hacks with--
PROFESSOR: What is going on?
STUDENT: Two oscillators.
STUDENT: Do you want
to jump in on those?
STUDENT: We can
do one at a time.
PROFESSOR: There you go.
OK.
STUDENT: How big is that cap?
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's pause.
Let's pause for a second, OK?
Now, the reason Greg
has the lower tone--
hear your nice tone-- is because
of different capacitors being
used.
So the capacitor going
from pin one to the ground.
By varying that
path capcitor, we
can set a different frequency
range for the oscillation.
The principle we're using
here for oscillation
is feedback, right?
We're taking the
output of pin two,
feeding it back into pin one,
which through the resistor,
that is causing the 1 to flip
to 0, the 0 to flip to 1,
and continually producing
what kind of sound?
Is it essentially?
STUDENT: Sawtooth.
PROFESSOR: Something like
a sawtoothed squarish.
It's going from 1 to 0
but it's going to fall,
so it's not going to be
a straight square wave,
but it's going to be
something square-like.
Everybody happy with the
first synthesizer they built?
STUDENT: It's like a nice It's
looks like a nice helicopter.
PROFESSOR: OK, now, we
can have immediate fun
by replacing our resistor
with the photoresistor.
The photoresistor allows
us to bury resistance.
If we bury the resistance
in the feedback from pin one
to pin two, what will
we be able to do?
STUDENT: Change the pitch.
PROFESSOR: Change the
frequency of oscillation.
So some of you have
already done it.
STUDENT: I'm going to borrow
the amp from you guys.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So here we go.
STUDENT: You could do
this all too high before.
PROFESSOR: It's OK.
You should [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: These things
are not directional?
STUDENT: The big black one is.
STUDENT: The big black one.
STUDENT: Yeah.
Where the one lead
goes to ground.
STUDENT: Right.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, try
the smart capacitor.
Did it work fine with that?
Is this a 1 or--
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: This should
give you something.
STUDENT: Try changing the
pins at the photoresistors.
STUDENT: Oh, this
motor is not going
to-- We need the little one.
STUDENT: Oh.
Chris did bring a
whole [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: Oh, that's nice.
STUDENT: We're not even
getting the basic tone.
PROFESSOR: OK, so what you got?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There we go.
STUDENT: You guys want
to try it out again?
PROFESSOR: Let's
move this around.
If you haven't
got on the speaker
yet with your recent
configuration.
STUDENT: I didn't
expand in this motor.
STUDENT: Yeah.
Think more about it.
STUDENT: Maybe we go really
slow with a really big
and getting the pulses.
STUDENT: We're just
going to try to blow up.
PROFESSOR: And the whole
thing collects light
if you cover it all the way.
STUDENT: This is like a--
STUDENT: Oh, that's
going to change things.
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
Let me move the speaker around.
STUDENT: Let's pull
it down a little bit.
STUDENT: We're trying to
figure out [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
And let's do-- OK, let's pause.
Let's pause.
OK, so we discovered
with the photoresistor
we can vary the frequency.
By swapping out
different capacitors,
we can get different
frequency ranges.
Why don't you swap
out the-- do you
have that big
electric capacitor?
Swap that out with
the other capacitor.
STUDENT: This made
it really high,
but if we use the big-- yeah.
STUDENT: It's going
to be a nice flow.
STUDENT: And controllable.
STUDENT: What we really
want is control board.
PROFESSOR: Pause.
Pause.
Here we have a larger
capacitor which gives us
some really nice low
frequency tone, which
I think are pleasing.
Now, to get even a more pleasing
tone, what we're going to do
is insert a diode
into the output,
which is a hack
that Collins uses.
And somebody can explain to
me why this sounds better,
but it sounds nice when we stick
the signal through a diode.
So we're going to take
the output of pin two,
put it through
the diode and then
pick up that output from there.
And the diode is
directional, so you
want to make sure [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: Well, I
guess maybe it just
depends on the polarity
of the whole thing.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I used the black end
to turn up the output.
STUDENT: It's just
going to shave off
even the top of the wave
or the bottom of the wave.
PROFESSOR: And it also
makes it really loud.
STUDENT: Really.
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we're taking the
signal from into-- good.
OK, you're ready.
STUDENT: Maybe if
it's a lot louder
now it's enough to
drive our motor.
STUDENT: Oh, yes.
STUDENT: The
ensemble is perfect.
STUDENT: Very the frequency.
PROFESSOR: You're
not using this cap,
because you're missing the pin.
Try getting that in there.
STUDENT: Oh.
STUDENT: What happened?
STUDENT: Nothing.
PROFESSOR: There we go.
Now let's hear that.
Now that's a nice tone.
And if you cover
it all around, it's
actually sensitive all over.
STUDENT: Oh wow.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it's--
STUDENT: It's probably got a
tiny little sawtooth that's
just not enough to--
STUDENT: It sounds
better with the diode.
STUDENT: You guys are
going to get some crazy--
STUDENT: I know.
STUDENT: We have an
ensemble going here.
PROFESSOR: OK.
You get this diagram?
STUDENT: Oh, that's great.
STUDENT: Turn that
overdrive way up.
STUDENT: It's a pyramid.
STUDENT: I'm just just an LFO.
PROFESSOR: I thought it
was a problem that I only
had two amplifiers, but
it's actually a good thing.
STUDENT: Whoa.
Look at this.
We have three sets
all together here.
I noticed the--
PROFESSOR: OK, pause.
All right.
Now, the last thing we're going
to do, which I'm amazed we
have time to try
it, but we'll try
to do Collins' very
simple low path filter
circuit, which is a total hack.
But all we have to do is insert
another resistor-- actually,
a photoresistor and a
capacitor to the output.
I have the diagram
for this somewhere.
This will give us, with
another photoresistor,
our essential two parameters,
which should help us.
STUDENT: Should we keep
the diode in there?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I like to keep the
diode in there.
So take the output of the
diode and then-- and now
take a photoresistor from this
bus, put them in the next one,
and then capcitor to ground.
Try the filter.
You need to be-- oh wait.
This should do it.
Turn it up a little bit.
STUDENT: Whoa.
PROFESSOR: No, the first one.
Oh, you're up all the way.
STUDENT: Well past filters.
STUDENT: Maybe if we--
STUDENT: When I touch it--
STUDENT: Yeah, you're
bridging it turning it on?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
It's time to make some music.
We're going to do duets.
So and you guys will
be a trio, obviously.
So why don't we
start with you guys.
You guys and you guys.
We'll go from the sides,
and then we'll-- oh,
we can do you four
at the same time.
OK.
That's great.
STUDENT: What do we try to play?
PROFESSOR: OK, you're going
to do an improvisation.
It's going to be a
minute or two minutes.
And we're going to use a
very simple improvisation
technique that works
in almost any context.
STUDENT: Call and response.
PROFESSOR: No.
What we're going to do is
set up a basic ostinati.
So you're going to repeat
some musical motive.
Find some little thing
that you can repeat.
It can be a little [SOUND].
Some little gesture
that's identifiable
and repeat it, and
keep on repeating it.
It's like a drum
circle basically.
But we're using our
photoresistor therabins
to do a drum circle.
So you'll start off, you'll
create a sort of pattern,
and then hold it.
The next person
will come in, try
to do something that fits
in with that pattern.
After it's going, then you can--
STUDENT: And then we'll
hop flop to Andrew.
PROFESSOR: --change the pattern.
STUDENT: Oh.
PROFESSOR: --a little bit.
And then it'll be done.
[STUDENTS PLAYING PATTERNS]
Guys, you guys were coming down.
There was this good
ending opportunity there.
When you hear it ending, use it.
It's good to get out
while you're ahead.